good morning john i feel like probably
we could all use a little change of pace
so i'm just going to sit in my yard
which has turned out quite lovely
this year with just lots of plants and i
just want to be
in the plants and i'm taking a huge from
you because question tuesday sounded
good to me
sounded simple sounded like something i
can do joseph wants to know what my
favorite pelican species is
the brown pelican i know you're thinking
white pelicans are much more majestic
and there's a dalmatian palette there's
lots of different kinds of pelicans but
brown pelicans have the closest to my
heart and they seem very nice
they just seem like nice birds i didn't
expect there to be leaf blowing
i thought bird song would happen i
thought you know this
tree would touch me in the head the
whole time i didn't expect
yard work at nine o'clock at night and
yes
this is what it looks like at nine
o'clock at night in montana penguicorn
says
how are you not constantly talking about
your book i'm reading it and unable to
not keep talking about it that's great
and i
love talking about my book i mean i said
i loved you but
this is a little much now i love talking
about my book and i love hearing people
talk about my book and i spend a lot of
time
reading the things that people are
saying about my book that is a fun
little bird noise
what are you swallows my neighbor's
windows
open and he can
song to listen to recently think about
things
by daddy freyr i know i'm not
pronouncing that right
that's all that's the only one it's so
good
april wants to know if i could spare
some change for gas money
uh absolutely just let me know your
venmo sarah wants to know why pelicans
they're just
really good birds in general i've been
on a bird kick lately thanks to jason
ward mostly you should check out his
show and i just
love it they're just good and pelicans
are maybe the best of them is that
controversial
probably entirely subjective definitely
but i love them look at them look at
this one look at this one
this one this one how is that not your
favorite bird rachel just was diagnosed
with adhd
and a lot of things are clicking into
place advice gosh you guys
9 15. biggest piece of advice
is just because your brain works
different
doesn't mean that it works worse also
watch how to adhd
great channel different cat wants to
know who did you play when you did rocky
horror shows
i've tried numerous times to find out
well maybe i should just like go ahead
and show the photo
it was all worth it wasn't it i was
rocky if you didn't know what that means
rachel
wants to know what my favorite
microorganism is i'm gonna go with lacro
maria but that's just today
who knows how i'll feel tomorrow i don't
think we've done a microcosmos just on
lacro mario yet we talk about them a lot
in the predation episodes because
they're great at eating the stuff but i
think we're going to do a specific
lacrimaria episode soon and finally
laura asks this question it's getting
dark out
and likewise she says these are dark
days so how do you lift your head to the
light
when the darkness is so heavy oh my
laura i make things with people i love
when i have the opportunity to do that i
also
look at birds and i think that that's
really important and i
i try and let my curiosity lead me to
interesting places
because finding stuff out and this is
just for me is one of the only
like completely undependent
on the rest of the world things that
brings
me satisfaction and joy that and of
course
other people and my relationships and i
think that
finding strength in community and
love that's the thing that's carrying me
through so i hope that
there are opportunities for that for you
as well john
thank you for being a part of that of
that curiosity of that making stuff
and of that love and i will see you not
this tuesday but next tuesday because
you're taking tuesday off
oh my god a mosquito oh geez i'm really
gotta go inside now i hope my neighbors
understand that this is what i do